die künstliche intelligenz erreicht
schon jetzt eine neue stufe sie
entwickelt das design von chips für
künstliche intelligenz ki für sich
selbst die maschinen fangen an sich
selbst zu bauen und in rasendem tempo
weiter zu entwickeln wird kann jetzt
schon gefährlich und unkontrollierbar
klicks umsatz im future gibt es da mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
wie kann baut sich selbst eines der
größten horror szenarien der zukunft
pessimisten allerdings zunächst klingt
das alles erst mal ziemlich harmlos
computer handys und viele andere geräte
der kommunikations und
informationstechnik ohne sie wären wir
aufgeschmissen keine frage computerchips
haben unser ganzes leben revolutioniert
kleine wunder der technik und so gefragt
wie nie zuvor
denn es gibt mittlerweile kaum mehr ein
gerät das ohne sie auskommt und ihr
aufbau ist nicht ohne computer chips
bestehen aus vielen vielen einzelnen
blöcken wii-controller speicher und
rechenmodelle nicht zu vergessen viele
kilometer kontakt trete auf engstem raum
solche prozessoren verfügen also über
äußerst komplexe grundrisse und dass auf
der fläche an der kleinen briefmarke
milliarden von verschiedenen komponenten
also die auf einem stück silizium von
der größe eines fingernagels angeordnet
sind und verbunden
tausende von speicher blöcken die auch
als makro blöcke bezeichnet werden so
wie viele millionen von sogenannten
logik gattern als standard zählen
bekannt diese müssen dann alle platziert
und miteinander verdrahtet werden am
ende entscheidet das darüber wie schnell
signale auf dem chip übertragen werden
können also im endeffekt auch wie
effizient das endgerät sein wird eine
wirklich mühselige arbeit an der
ingenieurinnen und ingenieure teils
monatelang sitzen ihr job ist es unter
anderem die vielen millionen
speicherbausteine und schalter elemente
so anzuordnen dass der chip wie
gewünscht funktioniert dazu die google
wissenschaftlerin anna goldie wie können
wir speicherbausteine und logik gatter
so auf dem chip platzieren dass
stromverbrauch und
minimal werden menschliche fachleute
brauchen dafür heute auf zwei bis drei
jahren eine äußerst zeitintensive arbeit
also die notwendig ist um die
bestandteile so anzuordnen dass sowohl
die energieeffizienz als auch die
rechenleistung des computerchips den
erwartungen gerecht wird das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
alleine für das sogenannte snow planning
also die platzierung der großen makro
blöcke gibt es potenziell 10 hoch 2500
verschiedene konfigurationen die anzahl
der möglichen layout ist also eigentlich
kaum zu überblicken das ist eine eins
mit 2500 0 1 hinten dran und so müssen
die grundrisse des chips in vielen
einzelnen schritten angepasst werden
eine hochkomplexe aufgabe
doch bisher ist es fachleuten weltweit
trotz intensiver forschung noch nicht
gelungen diesen prozess des chip designs
zu automatisieren zwar gibt es computer
software die ein kleiner support ist
dennoch gehen meist immer noch viele
monate ins land ehe dann feststeht wie
und wo die einzelnen komponenten am
besten montiert werden und die
komplexität wird nicht kleiner ganz im
gegenteil zumindest wenn man nach dem
sogenannten motion gesetz geht demnach
verdoppelt sich die komplexität
integrierter schaltkreise regelmäßig oft
spricht man auch von der verdopplung der
integrationsdichte gemeint ist damit die
anzahl der transistoren also halbleiter
bauelemente pro flächeneinheit genau
richtig kommt da jetzt also 1 km modell
eines google forschungsteams das den
chip designerinnen und designern
diese intensive arbeit abnehmen könnte
denn derzeit herrscht eine weltweite
knappheit an chips die nachfrage zieht
stetig an
denn halbleiter sind für so wahnsinnig
viele produkte unverzichtbar
doch durch die korona pandemie gab es
massive probleme bei der produktion
betroffen sind davon viele sektoren
unter anderem die automobilindustrie und
die unterhaltungselektronik manche
bezeichnen halbleiterchips deswegen
sogar als das öl des 21 jahrhunderts
tatsächlich sind sie entscheidend dafür
dass die digitale wirtschaft
funktioniert googles neueste modell
könnte also kaum zu einem besseren
zeitpunkt kommt und die ergebnisse die
jetzt im renommierten fachmagazin nature
publiziert wurden beeindruckend sogar
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler wie
genau funktioniert das neue modell und
was kann es wirklich ist es also eine
gefahr oder ganz harmlos um zunächst
klingt es auch mehr als harmlos die
basis für die entwicklung moderner
mikrochips wurde übrigens bereits im
jahr 1958 gelegt und seitdem ist viel
passiert damals waren die computer noch
so groß wie kleiderschränke und immer
mehr komponenten sollten platz finden
denn ob man es glaubt oder nicht die
computer von damals erreichten kaum die
leistung eines heutigen taschenrechners
der us ingenieur jack kirby hatte sich
in den kopf gesetzt dieses problem zu
lösen so gelang es ihm erstmals
kondensatoren widerstände und
transistoren auf einem winzigen bauteile
zusammen zu bauen das war tatsächlich
der grundstein für eine mächtige
industrie die unser aller privat und
arbeitsleben verändern sollte und jetzt
möglicherweise eine weitere
bahnbrechende erfindung das neue modell
von google dazu eine der beteiligten
google forscherinnen anna goldie wir
verwenden einen lernfähigen algorithmus
der die komponenten nacheinander auf dem
chip platziert eine nach der anderen
zwischendrin erhält er immer wieder eine
art belohnung signal
es sagt dem algorithmus wie gut er seine
arbeit erledigt hat und was er besser
machen kann
auf diese weise wird der algorithmus mit
der zeit immer leistungsfähiger
die rede ist hier also von einem
neuronalen netzwerk das den menschlichen
gehirns nachempfunden ist verwendet
wurde ein datensatz von 10.000 chip
layout um die ki zu füttern und zu
trainieren
die ersten ergebnisse der ki sind also
nicht gut wenn das netz agiert rein nach
zufall doch das belohnungs signal sorgt
dafür dass es immer besser wird das
neuronale netz programmiert sich dabei
selbst nachdem diese schleife mehrere
tausend mal durch gelaufen ist können
sich die ergebnisse des neu entwickelten
km modells wirklich sehen lassen nach
angaben des forschungsteams entwickelt
die ki ein optimiertes chipdesign für
das menschen wochen oder eben sogar
monate oder sogar jahre brauchen würden
demnach sind die ergebnisse der sogar
qualitativ besser als von menschenhand
dazu heißt es von den google
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern
unsere methode generiert automatisch
stück grundrisse die in allen
schlüsselfunktionen vergleichbar oder
sogar
besser sind als vom menschen geschaffene
vom energieverbrauch über die
leistungsfähigkeit bis zur größe des
chips doch was genau macht der
algorithmus er ordnet die einzelnen
blöcke eines chips selbstständig und
virtuell an und schätzt sie daraus
folgenden leistungsparameter ab so ist
die ki also in der lage viele tausende
verschiedene grundrisse zu vergleichen
und zwar innerhalb von kürzester zeit
dabei wird das system immer besser und
lernten mit der zeit welche grundrisse
und ordnungs strategien sich am besten
auf die rechenleistung dem platz und
strombedarf auswirken
interessant ist dabei vor allem eine
sache die von der ki gestalteten
grundrisse sehen ganz anders aus als die
der menschlichen chip entwicklerinnen
und entwickler auf den ersten blick
wirken sie total chaotisch und
ungeordnet die baupläne der menschen
dagegen scheinen sehr streng geordnet
doch die leistungsfähigkeit in
kombination mit kurzer entwicklungszeit
die überzeugt für die fachleute ist das
übrigens auch als ein hinweis zu sehen
dass die bislang gewählten strategien
möglicherweise verbesserungswürdig sind
die google wissenschaftlerin anna goldie
twittert unser agent trade fairs and
learning generiert schiff layout in nur
wenigen stunden pro gegen menschliche
experten monate brauchen können laut
google kann das neu entwickelte modell
auf alle möglichen sorten von chips
angewandt werden für google selbst sind
vor allem aber zwei bereiche
zusammenhang der künstlichen intelligenz
besonders wichtig die bildersuche und
die routenberechnung das google team
sagt dazu im moment sind keine
algorithmen für die hardware optimiert
die wir heute haben
bislang mussten wir jahre auf eine neue
hardware generation warten und damit
auch die möglichkeit neue ki software zu
erproben
indem wir das verkürzen können wir
schneller zu neuen chips kommen auf
denen dann die algorithmen der zukunft
laufen können sprich tatsächlich
entwickelt sich hier ein kreislauf in
dem die ki die hardware immer schneller
weiterentwickelt da ja die ki auf der
neuen hardware die jetzt immer schneller
entwickelt wird immer schneller neue
bessere hardware entwickeln kann eine
exponentielle entwicklung die
entwicklung wird also immer schneller
schneller es muss ja also sehr genau
hingeschaut werden denn so kann die ki
eben immer schneller schneller werden
und uns vielleicht schneller überflügeln
als
die anden noch ist das zukunftsmusik
doch die zukunft ist näher als wir
denken und durch diese entwicklung ist
sie uns noch näher gekommen wie schnell
die entwicklung in zahlreichen bereichen
voran geht das habe ich übrigens in
meinem buch per aufzug in den weltraum
mit zahlreichen beispielen beschrieben
egal ob klimawandel quantencomputer oder
eben künstliche intelligenz diese
veränderungen kommen schneller als wir
denken das buch gibt es in allen guten
buchhandlungen oder ihr unter diesem
link also los lesen und die zukunft
mitgestalten ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran